toki monster first and foremost thank
you so much for making the time today
thanks for having me now we're here to
talk about asian heritage month and
we're going to get to that at length but
i needed to do a little bit of
investigative journalism here
you have a beautiful cat named misha but
i can't help but wonder how do you fit
his head into that little stuffed
doughnut
it has a it has a drawstring so i don't
know if you know the back story but he
just got his leg amputated so instead of
the cone of shame get the little donut
so he looks
like less shame i guess he feels less
shame than the donut i don't know he
makes me happy in the donut
figure it's better to have fun around
his head so you have a little drawstring
and you just like put it
put it over his head and then you just
like that is adorable i hope we see more
of those kona shames
swapped out for the donuts it's a nice
touch of glory
we'll call it that donut of glory that's
a perfect name for it um
and now as someone who has a terrible
ear for music
i in terms of like creating it and
understanding the process of it
i love to talk to musicians because you
can hopefully put me up on game a little
bit
are there any comparisons you can draw
from
your experience as a classical pianist
and electronic music
um you know it really depends on the
musician and the producer
some people don't operate from the same
lens or perspective that i do and i
think that i have a very unique
perspective in terms of my my version of
electronic music because of that
classical background
um i guess for anyone kind of familiar a
lot of classical music tends to be very
um i don't know it's kind of more like a
journey it's a lot of storytelling
and i think with electronic music i
offer the lens that
of of a song that can kind of tell a
story where there's a beginning a middle
and
an end but a lot of electronic music is
just
loops over and over again and that's
cool too you know
for sure let's get into it a bit it's
asian heritage month and that's what
we're here to celebrate over at et
canada and in particular this year
it seems like it's on people's minds
more often than usual because
unfortunately
we have seen this uptick in um
anti-asian rhetoric violence against
asian people
and the stop asian hate movement
for you what is the best way in which
people can be an
ally to supporting their asian
communities
for me the first and foremost
i would say educating yourself you know
it it's one of those things right now
where people don't understand they never
knew that
this violence existed like oh you know
the asian community it's
been fine right because you know there
is um a long history with many asian
cultures
um sort of internalizing a lot of the
issues that they go
they deal with especially as immigrants
in this country where i know
uh speaking personally with my family my
mother was like we don't
like something happens we don't say
anything you know and now we're finally
speaking out
uh we have to because the acts are just
so blatant and
there's no way to ignore them but yeah
i think educating yourself on sort of
the asian american experience or you
know
this westernized asian experience what
it's like to be in this country
asking your friends what it's like
asking your friends if they're okay
um it's been pretty fatiguing fatiguing
on a lot of us so
those are a few few steps are there any
resources that come
to mind where people who perhaps maybe
don't have asian friends nearby can look
into
uh they're stopping i guess if you were
the easiest way i would say
is just to search the hashtag stop agent
hate
there's just a multitude of resources so
many talented graphic designers made all
these like cool little graphics
on uh ways that you can help places that
you can donate to
um it is it is pretty incredible you
know
uh there are organizations that are just
to help you know
asian america or asian women for example
because they're the most marginalized
and there are ways to help the elderly
right now because they are
the main targets i am not one to say
them off the top of my head
but a good google search will will give
you all those
all those answers well that is plenty
that is funny i thank you for that
i want to sort of flip the question you
touched on it and you have in the past
that
um in many asian cultures you've said
there is
um a culture of being humble and not
burdening others you spoke about how
your mom sort of
told you you know you need to be putting
yourself out there like that is there
anything you'd like to say
to uh your fellow asians and people of
asian descent who might be in those
cultures where they feel like they
shouldn't speak out we are a completely
different generation than
our parents and their parents and with
each generation i truly believe that
people evolve
and just because they did it and they
thought it worked for them to stay quiet
doesn't mean it's gonna work for us and
it's not
it's not working for us clearly we can
see so
we have to find that strength in
ourselves that courageous
nature to speak out and defend each
other and protect each other because
no one knows your experience except you
right and all our experiences are very
unique but as a community
we are just so much stronger together
and if we can just find that
that brave attitude and go out there and
speak on this things will change and you
can even see even the fact that we're
talking
about this now that's we didn't talk
about it like a couple years ago not in
the way that we are now
that's all because the community has
decided to speak up and
make some changes you were featured
prominently in a documentary called
underplayed along with alice in
wonderland canada's own res which
tackled
gender inequality in the electronic
scene and the wider music industry as a
whole
have you ever experienced any sort of
inequality in the music industry based
on your
uh background your ethnicity oh man i
think
i'm just the culminating combination of
all my identities right so
sometimes it's not even easy to say they
can just
give me someone could give me a weird
glance and i don't know because i'm a
woman and i don't or i don't know if
it's because i'm asian
um i will say that asians
do kind of well in electronic music if
you want to compare
the the um i guess proportion of
asians like participating in this
particular genre if you want to compare
it to like rap for example not a lot of
like
mainstream asian rappers but you know
there really aren't a lot and there are
ways that people tend to judge
like asian people in the arts and it is
very i think to make it in this industry
you just have to try extra hard so
i know it's done something and i've had
a lot of unpleasant experiences
but at the same time i also am about
putting my best foot forward making the
best music i can existing as the best
version of myself so people can look at
me
and say oh she represents asian people
she represents a woman and she's really
good
and at that point hopefully people
behind like after me if not behind me
but after me will not be
judged or looked at in the same way
i think that's a perfect swing in
momentum and tone because well
and i appreciate you so much for taking
the time to talk to me about this stuff
there's a lot of
terrible things that have happened
recently that we need to speak more
about
i'd also love to take some time for
asian heritage month and celebrate some
people so
the first thing i want to ask you in
that regard who are some of the role
models of asian descent either in your
personal
or professional life that uh
professional lives that deserve a
standing ovation
for me personally it would be my mom she
was just
the strongest hardest working woman and
she taught me from a very young age and
this is not
a common ideology within especially her
generation of like asian parents
she's like you gotta get your own
basically she doesn't use that term but
you know
um at the end of the day you need to
have the skills to support yourself and
you don't know what's going to happen
you know you don't know if you're going
to have
a husband that's going to take care of
you or a husband in general or
kids or no kids or all these things you
need to be self-sufficient
and that was something that was very
forward-thinking
in my opinion for her generation and
she is a single mother and she dealt
with a lot of shame
being a single mother and she didn't
impart that on me
so she is the best role model ever and
as far as in music
there aren't a lot of there weren't a
lot of
asian female music people that i could
look up to so
i'll just take that role upon myself and
hopefully i can be a role model for
the next generation shout out to moms uh
what is one really cool fun or
interesting thing about korean culture
that you
cherish or that people might not be
aware of
ooh okay let's get the mainstream things
out of the way
all the kpop i get it we love it
um the kdramas everyone loves that too
um you know that's something that's
really beautiful about the culture is
how everyone takes care of each other
and
this is something you might not
experience unless you have like a really
good korean homie or you get to visit
korea but
your friends your korean friends will
always show up for you and they'll show
up for you even when you don't want them
to show up for you like at your front
door if you're sad or um
if you're visiting they'll welcome you
by taking you out and having you do
the most amazing fun things and eating
the most amazing fun foods and i know
this is a bit more of a
non-specific kind of cultural
um characteristic but i think it's a
really lovely one and
you really feel it especially if you go
visit so everyone should go visit
what is your favorite bite of korean
food oh my god
this is so hard um i am a sucker for kfc
which is korean fried chicken
it is very excellent um barbecue's
always good
a very simple homemade meal is a kimchi
jjigae so kimchi
is like a kimchi stew and usually has
like pork belly
and it's kind of spicy but not too spicy
it's good and it's like a home staple
well what are those spicy rice cakes
called those are just
to die for oh those ones are like
you gotta be careful it's like you go to
a place and you'll be like this is
this is wonderful the right amount of
spice you go to another place and it'll
look like blow your head off
perfect as we wrap up here you did tease
some
music announcements coming soon on
instagram
i take it that means you can't tell me
but i have to try is there anything you
can share about your upcoming releases
okay so i have a single
coming out at the end of this month and
even if i knew the date
i don't know the date i forgot i already
forgot everything i do
in my life has to end up on a calendar
of some sort but towards the end of this
month i have a brand new
single i haven't released original music
in quite a while so i'm very excited and
it has really cool features
and hopefully it'll make people like
want to move around a little you know
especially as things start opening up
too
exactly